the Joe Rogan experience I grew up a lot
of shellfish and I've noticed a lot of
my New York friends can't eat shellfish
yeah that's real common yeah common but
it's so good imagine not having shrimp I
know that's kooky I would have to kill
myself we found out on fear factor that
if you're allergic to shellfish you all
you're also allergic to roaches what
yeah I grew up with both of those
they're you know not eating wrote but we
had a shitty house we have an episode of
fear factor we serve these people in
Madagascar hissing cockroaches as throat
started closing up just seeing it it's
know just being around at 108 one call
the EMT and I think they shoot you up
with a gentleman I think wow yeah we had
did you have roaches in your house as a
kid oh yeah me too and they would fly
remember that remember tonight the New
Orleans thing yeah I grew up in the
heart of New Orleans remai was the name
my neighborhood Theo Vaughn was like
more sticks
outside of it but I was I was in the
city and it was terrifying it was a
rough-and-tumble City when I was there
yeah my dad got a wild hair possess and
bought a match a dilapidated mansion in
a poor black neighborhood and you know
like no running water for a while he
turned the back half into a
bed-and-breakfast because we ran out of
money it was I was afraid we got robbed
all the time because we were the white
family in the neighborhood and everybody
thought we had money because of our big
house so we got robbed constantly I
walked in on a couple robberies as a kid
my alarm would go off at like 2:00 in
the morning is that like an 8 year old
that's you just know there's a guy in
your living room scrapping around oh it
was banana that's why I'm so squirrely
cuz that really [ __ ] with me well for
sure my bike got stolen all the time
from under me I had a transvestite nanny
well growing up named eNOS I know this
sounds crazy but uh they don't use that
word anymore
was that transvestite well he would he
wasn't trans he just had women's
clothing on right mrs. Doubtfire right
but like they don't was last time you
saw someone even refer to things that
way what does a drag queen I don't know
what you would call it now I mean it
either you're trans you transgender or
you non-binary
what are you he was a dude he was a big
black dude right he looked like Ving
Rhames but he would wear high heels and
a wig yeah and he would sweep the house
so was he
Trane's yeah would you say dick I don't
say trans and then it has is all
inclusive transvestite in Turkey yeah I
guess why not right yeah but that's a
big umbrella
I think they've abandoned transvestite
but it has a meaning it's the clothing
it is but I don't know well is is it I
would look I transvestitism comes up on
Wikipedia when I change three letters or
else you go about control these this
language is all control it's certainly a
big part of it compliance is a big part
of what's going yes comply want you to
comply I call it compassion yeah okay
crossdresser
where's the compassion with a guy who
loves sorry getting lost in the weeds so
I had a transgender transvestite nanny
and he taught me everything he taught me
how to fight and put the seat up and
like go on a date with a girl on how to
do this with a car yeah because my
parents were always working because the
house was so big they had to afford it
that's so ridiculous it was crazy man we
had we had roaches and mice and we I
remember we didn't have lights in the
house we had those like mechanic lamps
in your room that's how you really yeah
like had a light in your room it was a
weird way to grow up but then the back
half was serene it was like a
bed-and-breakfast and we had travelling
musicians and like a zijn Asian
businessmen coming in I tried to pitch
this as a show and everybody's like this
is too dark nobody would take it but the
racial tension was insane and how many
times you guys think you're wrong oh I
mean you get robbed real good like six
times a year oh oh yeah oh yeah and you
guys stayed yeah how about this so eNOS
was like my male role model you know
this big black guy in a wig and one time
I was riding home from summer camp and
you know these three street toughs you
know we're put you know coming up next
to me three of them like hey man let us
try your bike and I was like I'm good
you know I knew what they wanted and I
was like I'm good no thank you and
they're like come on they're doing their
their back tire or their front tire
against my back you know that move and
starting to skid me out a little bit so
I go alright alright and these kids are
17 I'm probably like 13 and they're like
alright let me just try it so I remember
I kept my hand on the handle and he got
on it he's like and he just brushed my
hand away and just went check yeah
and row it off and I was like guy so I
ran home crying and I got there and eNOS
like what happened I'm like huh
couple kids took my bike and it was like
the fourth time so he's like [ __ ] that
get in the van oh my god good you know
I'm so defeated you know I'm so it's so
emasculating you feel like a [ __ ] so I
was like I'm good he's a get in the van
we had a big van and we're driving
around the neighborhood looking for my
bike I don't see these guys again I just
want to let it go and he's like we're
gonna find that bike we're driving
around and we go some back streets and
we see these kids on a stoop like taking
it apart you know cuz you got a
camouflage with a little so I'm like and
he's like is that your bike I'm like
yeah I'm slunt down and shotgun like
yeah my bike let's just get out of here
[ __ ] it abort and he goes up to these
guys he walks up to these guys and he's
wearing high heels a wig and like a
v-neck and he looks weird it's the 90s
and he goes up to these guys and they're
all going they all lose it because I
like look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] they're
all going crazy and they're flipping out
and call him names and stuff and this
guy was stone cold and he goes that's
not your bike and they go what are you
gonna do about it and this is like five
kids with tools you know and he goes I'm
gonna take it back and they were like I
don't think you are or whatever and I
remember he put his hand on the middle
bar of the bike just to kind of see what
happened looked him in the eye
yanked it and he said that's what I
thought through the bike over shoulder
walked to the van slid the door open
threw it in close the door we drove home
unbelievable I mean talk about a 13 year
old seeing like that's like oh that's
what a man is that was that changed my
life
Wow unbelievable I never wrote it again
my idea what if they beat him to death
with wrenches well then I was stuck in
the van crying I would have learn to
drive real quick but no I didn't leave
the keys I think he did yeah I think it
was running but I just because you know
when your kid and you see these bully
types you're just like I could never
beat him yeah and then it's a see
someone beat him was so it was
mind-boggling
I loved him ever since that I mean I
loved him before but uh he's still in
talks with him now he died he got killed
in a sexual encounter oh well he was
hooking up with a guy and the dawn came
out and the guy flipped and killed him
yeah he was like a burlesque dancer by
night so he got it he got it you know
New Orleans is a it's a wild devil of a
lady but yeah he he was a good egg and
I'm I I needed him growing up cuz my I
had no parents around you know my
parents are weird guy I don't know if
you noticed but I can't make eye contact
I've been doing it pretty good but uh
yeah I don't know I don't know how to
connect but that eNOS stuff was great he
was a cool dude
[Applause]